You know what the key is to these cold opens? You just start talking and stuff just tumbles out of the mouth. It's halfway interesting. Go ahead, Will, give it a shot. Just start yammering. Oh man, taxis in this year really got me in knots. That's pretty good. Thanks man. That's pretty good stuff. You think that's good? Wait till this all new Smartless.
Nice. Welcome to Smartless. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
Smart. Less. Well, where are you? I'm in the office. I'm in the office. I'm in the office. I'm in the office. I'm in the office.
I'm in the office. I'm in the office. I'm in the office. I'm in the office. I'm in the office. I'm in the office. I'm in the office. Well, where are you? I'm at home now. I know. Why did you switch places? Because I was at my office as they were doing work here. Oh, that's right.
Oh, that's right. Remember the office, Sean? Yeah, that was extraordinary. Yeah, that lasted for just one recording. And now he's away from that work site. Ruh! Yeah. You know, it's so funny, you just have such a funny thing.
Don't make me go deep on this. Your thing about work, you think that you go to office. Hey, I'm actor, my new role is work. Look at his, look at him. Again, I grew up, I did everything I could to not do that. Right, you know what I mean? You nailed it. You don't want to step behind a desk.
Yeah. Yeah. Right? That's my dad, I mean, God bless him. Yeah, but we all sit behind desks during the day. Yes. I mean, right? We did everything.
No, not Will. Not me. Will sits on the couch and he watches the Toronto Maple Leafs win. Sure do. That's all he does. Oh, look at that. I tell you who captures the camera real well
is that Brendan Shanahan. He sure does, doesn't he? When they point that camera at him up in that power box. Yeah. I know. He's stuck there looking like the boss he is. He's turned into a real silver fox, hasn't he? Yeah, Cameron loves him.
By the way, he's going gonna call me and be like, what do you mean silver? You've got gray hair. It's a salt and pepper fox. Silver fox in a power box. I know. How about the time that he tried to teach Sean, Sean asked Shani when he was in town last year
to teach him how to fight at the Beverly Hills Hotel out the back door and Sean went at him. And he's like, okay, well, and Shani's laughing. Yeah, in two seconds he grabbed his shirt. Yeah, and Sean was saying, wait, aren't you supposed to take this off me? Isn't this shirt supposed to come off? I thought it was shirts against skins. I thought we were doing shirts against skins.
By the way, in high school, didn't you fear, well, hey Will, in high school, didn't you? Sean, that hurts. Now you're on board, thank you Sean. In high school, didn't it freak you out, or junior high, when the coach would say, okay, we're gonna do shirts and skins, and like in basketball or whatever. I would always.
I didn't wanna take my shirt off. I didn't wanna take my shirt off. I was always afraid of that. It's traumatizing. Why do they do that to kids? And then they made us take showers, and like 12, 13 years old. I'm like, I don't want to do that.
I know. Will likes walking around with his kid off, just kind of shaking his trunk all over the place. I never went to, I never stepped foot into a gym until I was about 24. So I was never like- Oh really? Yeah, ever.
Yeah, but you played sports. But I played sports, but I was, I just inched, yeah, ever. Yeah, but you played sports. I played sports, but I was, I just never, and then, but I went to boarding school, so I had to take showers, you know, starting at age 12 when I went to boarding school. Yeah, it's so like, I can't. Yeah, it was, it's weird. I went to camp once, I think I said this,
and we had a line up outside, a music camp, Blue Lake Fine Arts Camp in Michigan, and- Not a sports camp, Blue Lake Fine Arts Camp in Michigan. And they made a little. Not a sports camp. No. Huh, hang on, let me just, let me just adjust everything I know about you. Ha ha ha ha ha ha. And they made us line up outside to take a shower
in front of, and one by one, we had to take a shower. And you had to like, take your clothes off in front of all of these by one, we had to take a shower. And you had to like take your clothes off in front of all of these kids, your peers, and it was so awful. Sean, when I was in seventh grade, age 12, I went from living with my folks to a place where they had four showers per side in a big, huge open room with no divider.
Yeah, that's weird. It's like torture. Yeah, it's awful. And by the way, by the time I got in the camp thing, by the time I got up there, all the hot water was gone. So I was taking a cold shower, and I couldn't breathe. Well, if I'm being honest, you probably needed it. You're showering with all those dudes.
I mean, that probably helped. Just get things back to normal. Anything to calm me down. Yeah. Oh my God. What do you got some electrolytes going there, Sean? This morning? I do, yeah.
What happened to the milk? Is the cow dead? No, I had milk already. Oh, you're chasing it with some electrolytes? Good luck on the toy toy. What are you? Jesus, you're so obsessed with people's bell. Well, I just, I don't, he's creating a bomb. That electrolyte's gonna cut right through that milk
like a knife. Is it really? Yeah. Is it really? Yeah, dude. Whenever I see people eating, I'm not thinking. Get yourself over a toilet within the next 60 minutes. I'm never thinking about.
Well, let's wrap this up. Whenever I see people eat, I'm never thinking about, man, that's really gonna come back to haunt them on the toilet. It just doesn't occur to me. You know, when I see clips of that hot sauce talk show, that's all I think about. I know, same.
What are people doing? Same. You had your mind. No, they should do it from a toilet. Yeah. Yeah. You won't catch me on that show. No, of course not.
Not once. No, no, no, of course you won't. Whose guest is it today? Yeah, do you have a narcoleptic guest or something? Will, let's get to it. No, no, no, well, he's a great guest and I was about to get to it and then I was thinking about you talking
about shitting everywhere. But our guest, the only thing, he hasn't shit everywhere. All he's done is he's scored everywhere. This guy has been making everybody laugh. That's another word for it. He has been un, he's been making people shit themselves. He makes me shit myself laughing. He's so fucking funny.
He's such a great dude. I had the pleasure of kind of getting to know him over the last couple months. He's been very generous as I was going through the process on our film and he has just been, his specials have been unbelievably well received. He's maybe the biggest touring comic out there. His new, his show Tires is about to start
second season on June 5th. He's a great writer, he's an incredible standup, he's the funniest dude. Guys, it's Shane Gillis. Oh, Shane Gillis! You're on Smart List, good morning! Where is he, there he is. Hello! Hey guys, it's Shane Gillis. Oh, Shane Gillis! You're on Smart List, good morning! There he is.
Hello! Hey. I love you, this is so cool. Oh, thanks. Easy, easy. Yeah, so funny. Hi, Shane. Hi, Shane, hi, Shane.
Where do we find you today? Are you wee at home? I am at home, I'm in Austin, Texas. All right, and how is it in Austin? It's all right, it kind of sucks. It's hot and humid a lot. Hot already? I don't fucking, I don't love it. I don't love it.
Yeah, it's hot. It's been hot. It's going to be hot until December. Wow. It's one of the worst places I've ever lived. I hate it. Do you ever jump in that river that they call a lake and cool off a little bit?
Yeah, that's very nice. Why do they call it a lake? It does make it snakes around like a river, right? It's literally the Colorado River. I don't know, they call it a lake, I have no idea. Oh, I didn't know that. I didn't know that either. Is that something that happens down there?
Yes, it's just the Colorado River. And it doesn't even look like a lake, it's just a river. Yeah. There's just nothing like about it at all. You can throw a rock across it. Wait, so Shane, do you, you live there by choice? I mean, like, it sounds like you hate it. It sounds like you're being forced.
Like, is there somebody off camera with a gun? Yeah, Joe Rogan. He's right here. He's got a gun to my head. He's down there, right? Yeah, he's down here and he opened a club here and it was either, for a comedian, it's either New York, LA or,
that was always the only two options and then he opened a club here so you can,, for a comedian it's either New York, LA, or that was always the only two options. And then he opened a club here so you can, you know, you can evade some taxes and do stand-up here. Now he was a stand-up, right? And then I remember he was on one of the greatest shows ever, News Radio, so he was an actor for a minute, right? But he did start a stand-up, didn't he? He's still, I mean, he's done stand-up the entire time.
And remember Fear Factor? He did Fear Factor. Oh, that Factor? He did Fear Factor. Oh that's right. You should watch that. Fear Factor. So Shane, I first met Shane at Joe's club in Austin. Oh no way. Yeah, I went down there and he was kind enough
and gracious enough to let me have, twice have like 10 minutes of his time on stage. All right Shane, give us a review on Will. No, he doesn't, you don't have to. Yeah, no I want to hear it right now. No, it's going to be, Will doesn't want to hear it. Yeah, no, I want to hear it right now. No, it's going to be, Will doesn't want to hear it because it's flattering. Well, that's what I thought.
I was like, so they asked me to help write on this, write some for the movie. And I was like, if I write any material that's good, I need to keep it. You're going to keep it. Because I have nothing. Sure. So, I was like, the only way to do it is
just to actually do stand up. So, he came down and we did stand up and I was like, he only way to do it is just to actually do stand-up. So he came down and we did stand-up and I was like, he's gonna fucking bomb. This is a lot harder than he thinks. Yeah, so naturally funny right away. I was in the back of the room like, God damn it. He does have, Will you do have that that natural and I mean not as a pejorative, the sort of this ham gene, right? Like you are comfortable with the spotlight on you. I mean, not as a pejorative, sort of this ham gene, right? Like you are comfortable with the spotlight on you. You're comfortable giving a toast, you're comfortable.
I don't have that. I don't like the spotlight on me. I don't like a lot of attention. Will, you're comfortable with it and it puts the audience at ease. It's infectious. Yes, and it's a gift, it's a talent. Shane, you have it too.
Oh. Well, Shane's gift, it's a talent. Shane, you have it too. Oh. Well, Shane's got, here's the difference. I hemmed my way and hawed my way through it. Shane getting up there is so natural and good. And I know you've been working on it and you've crafted it, but you've got such a great way about you on stage. And you kind of, you bring, what I love is you kind of bring the audience in with you and you laugh and you,
I don't know, you kind of like, you don't really like take sides. You kind of like, you play to a wide audience, you play to different parts of what people, and you get to kind of just what's funny. So no matter where you land on any subject, you're like, you got to admit that's funny, whether you're talking about politics or whatever it is.
And I'm sure that that's not, I'm sure that's a skill, right? Like to be able to do that, that's something you kind of work on? I mean, I think it's kind of, I mean, yeah, it's a skill, I guess, but it's also like, that's kind of how I feel most of the time. I don't like picking a side on, I don't know,
publicly picking a side on an issue typically comes back to make you look like a fucking idiot. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. I don't know, I mean, unless it's like a glaring thing you should support, whatever. But I want to go back to the Austin thing. So the first show we went up and it was fine.
The second show we did like an hour later it was great. And it was really frustrating how good you were at it. Oh, with Will, yeah, yeah. And he was reading a script and it was still funny. He was using your material though. No, he wasn't. They did it themselves. In fact, I read the material first and I was like,
I don't think this is gonna fucking work. So wait, so what type of, what type? I didn't want to say anything. What was Will's style? Was he like telling stories or was he kind of going joke to joke to joke? It was more storytelling, but it was, it was exactly how I like the standup.
It was stories with jokes, with jokes within it, which was. Do you remember any of it, Willie? Or have you deleted the files? Can you give us a taste? No, well, a lot of it, as Shane knows, he read it because a lot of it is stuff that we use in the film, so we're working on it. So it's various stages of.
Yeah, because we didn't say it. This is the film that you just shot and that's coming out later this year. What's it called, Will, the film? Is This Thing On. Is This Thing, the film? Is This Thing On. Is This Thing On. Yeah. Is This Thing On.
We can get that on a later date when I'm the guest on the show. Yeah. Right. Are you going to book yourself? Oh, sorry. Go ahead, Shane. Sorry. No, we were laughing.
I was just at the cellar this week and we were laughing because there's a comedian there. His name's Will Sylvance and Will's playing a character on stage. And after the show, he goes on with the comedian and asks questions about the set, and I think he took the set very seriously. It was like, man, I'm really sorry you're going through all that. Oh, really?
That's great. That's a script, you idiot. He did, the first time I did New Joke Monday over there around the corner with him, and he comes up on stage and he asks you questions, and he was like, ooh, like Shane said, he was like, ah, it's not really rough, and I just kind of answered him as if it was all real,
and he's like, hang in there, buddy. Yeah, yeah. And we will be right back. And now, back to the show. Wait, Shane, so doing what you do for a living, do you wake up and go to sleep constantly thinking of like, I got it, like, that was funny today, this is funny, well, I got to write that down.
Like, do you ever get out of that or you were always in that mode? Yeah, I would say yeah, although I don't know I used to be a lot better at it now. I'm kind of just I Should be like that and I'm not okay. I got right on that I got to go back to only thinking about stand-up. Okay for real Yeah, yeah, I mean otherwise I don't know I you feel like you're not coming up with any new material Well, then how do you do what you do?
Do you set aside some time to really focus on work? No, I don't really write that much. I just kind of, I go, this could be a good idea, and then I go on stage and try it. And if I get it, great. So you just figure it out on stage, and it's all straight improv that you haven't really worked on any of it?
No, I mean, yeah, you do that for like, like I'll do, if I did stand up tonight, I would do basically 10 minutes that I know I'm, I know. But I just know every word to it. And then I'd maybe try five minutes and see what happens and probably abandon it and then have one of my friends in like four or five months go, hey, that was a funny idea and then I'll try it again.
And so when you're putting together an hour like to do a Netflix special, like, you know, are you, is that something like that they set the date for and they go, hey man, we need you to deliver this special by this date and so then that's when you kind of hone in and start working on actual stuff or I think they do that sometimes I told them I didn't really I wouldn't want to date on it maybe in 2026 because I got I got a right now I'm doing arenas and I don't think the best way to work an hour out
is in an arena it's just it's just different I don't know I think I'll do arenas for maybe the next, for the rest of this year and then go down back to clubs and really try to focus on hammering out the hour that I'm doing right now. I don't want to rush, it was special. When did you start? I love, I mean, you've got so much good stuff
that you talk about growing up. I love all that stuff about going to Notre Dame Games with your family. Yeah, that's my favorite. When you guys get in the van together and all that stuff about going to Notre Dame games with your family. Yeah, that's my favorite. When you guys get in the van together and all that stuff. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You've got such rich and your cousins and your family, you've just got such great rich stuff.
When, what was the first moment, this is like the question, like how did you start in comedy? But like, when did you start going like, oh, the stories that I'm telling about my family or the shit that's going on, people are laughing enough that I should go to a club and tell it in front of other people. Like, what was that?
Yeah, I was washing dishes at my friend's restaurant, and I always thought I was funny, and I just had no idea how to get into stand-up. And then one of the cooks was like, I'm gonna go do an open mic at the Harrisburg Comedy Zone tonight. And I was like, oh, you can just do stand-up? And he was like, yeah'm going to go do an open mic at the Harrisburg Comedy Zone tonight. And I was like, oh, you can just do stand up? And he was like, yeah.
So I went and I watched and I thought everyone sucked and I was like, I can do that. And then I went back every week for like two months just watching and then I finally got on stage and I fucking bombed. I was like, I don't have to write any material, I'm just funny. I just got up there and couldn't talk.
It was crazy how bad it was. And yeah, then it stopped for a while after that, traumatic experience, but I always still wanted to do it. And then eventually I went back and really applied myself and tried and did it. And were you studying to do anything else? Like was this always the career plan or did this derail something else?
No, it wasn't really. I was at Westchester University in Pennsylvania. I was studying to become a history teacher. Oh yeah? Wow. The first, I remember the first show I ever did. I fucking, it was a road, the first time I ever went on the road, it was a hotel outside of Pittsburgh in Mars, Pennsylvania,
and it was in like a hotel lobby, and I bombed so badly that the club owner took me aside and was like, what are you doing with your life? And I was like, I'm a college student, I'm studying to be a history teacher. He was like, why don't you just do that? Instead of stand up. I was like, alright man.
I kind of took it to heart. Were you done with your set yet? I swear to God it was in between shows. I still had another set. I had to go up there like, this might be it. This is my retirement. You know who loves history? Our host Will Arnett. Yeah, lives for it.
Specifically World War II history. What's your favorite? You like the European or the American? He knows it all, man. Right, Shane, you know it all. Well, I don't know. I like World War II. I like American Civil War is great.
Yeah, right. Have you seen both the Civil War documentary and the World War II documentary that Ken Burns did? Yeah. I love them both. Yeah, yeah. I like the Civil War one.
I like better. It's so powerful. The West, Vietnam is great. His Vietnam documentary was great. Yeah. Yeah. Because I didn't know shit about Vietnam. I remember, what did you say about the Ken Burns documentary?
You said that it's literally kryptonite for women? Yeah. Yeah. If you put it on, they're going to fall asleep. Yeah. I remember you used to talk, the other thing that really made me laugh, you used to talk about that dude Shelby Foot, that historian, and the way that he would, right?
I did that, I did a bunch of Ken Burns material in my SNL monologue. And everyone was kind of like, what the fuck is he talking about? That was it, that was it. That was hilarious. It was recent, it was recent, right? Yeah, every time my monologue doesn't go great on SNL,
I'm over two on those things. I loved it. I loved it too. I like it, look, I like it and I'm having fun up there, but it was, Tate McCray was the musical guest. So the audience was like 20 year old. Yeah. Mm-hmm chicks just in the front and I'm up there talking about fucking Shelby foot Just some ogre walked out on the stage and talked about Shelby Foote. They were probably scared.
You literally referenced the Battle of Fredericksburg. Shrek. Yeah. Hey, so with such a drastic, are you happy with where you're at? You find yourself at the top of your career in this particular field. At such a young age.
Which is drastically different than this other path that you thought you would be on. Like, have you adapted? Like, are you digging it? Right. It's, I don't know, you guys probably know what it's like. It's kind of uncomfortable. There's definitely some weird parts to it.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's pretty uncomfortable, you know, with the imposter syndrome and depression and all that, but, you know, I just drink a lot, so that helps. Yeah, around the edges. That really fucking makes things easier, you know? When you break up, you go off.
We all have the option to just sort of get off the highway and like, you know, hide, I guess. And you know, everyone forgets about you after a few years anyway, get off the highway and hide, I guess. And everyone forgets about you after a few years anyway, so we could find anonymity if we wanted it. Like, did you have that moment, I remember when you take, in your case, stand-up gigs or specials or whatever,
in my case it was a sitcom, and you. This guy! We love that joke! It was, and the first time that it started, I took it because it was a job, right? You audition, you're just looking for a job, and then you have no idea what's going to happen. You're just looking to feed yourself, and then you become famous.
It's like, oh! By accident almost, right? You just kind of want to work as an actor. It's not like, I want to be famous, I just want to work. And then it happens, and then in the moment, and I remember thinking, I'm like, oh, this is what, this is what I read about, this is what I watch TV and this happens.
So did that happen to you in that, do you remember that moment where you're like, oh shit, this is what it feels like to kind of become successful? Yeah, there was definitely some moments along the way. I mean, hosting SNL when I did that, that was one of those moments because I had gotten fired from the show before
and I was like, Oh, that's right, you were on it. Yeah, I just wanted to do it. Yeah, for four days. Yeah. Oh my God, really, for four days? Yeah, I remember seeing when they announced that you were going to host,
and it must have been kind of surreal considering the history you had. It was, I don't know, but it was like, oh great, we're going to go through this again. There was pressure, because once they announced it, everyone's like, fuck him, don't let him back, that. And it's like, I was fine without it. I was, you know, I'm doing all right.
But it was still awesome, and I was so happy know, I'm doing all right. But it was still awesome and I was so happy they let me back on and those people, everybody there has been, they've been awesome. But it was funny, back to the question was those moments, I was with my friend Dan Soder. He's one of the best comedians. Check him out. Super funny dude. His name's Dan Soder. I love him.
He's unbelievably funny. Yeah. But he was like one of the first people to take me on the road. And then he and I were doing an arena. We were doing like the Cleveland Cavaliers Arena. And I was standing in the tunnel before I went out there and I looked at him and I was like, dude, I really just wanted to do a one-nighter
at the local comedy club. I thought that was the ceiling. I don't know what the fuck this is. Hotel lobby would be nice. How I got here. Right. This has gotten out of hand. Wow.
And did you have, and so you have that moment before, and do you still have moments on stage where kind of out of body, where like you land a joke, and the place is going crazy, and you're standing, and I'm sure you're caught up in it, but you look out, and there are literally tens of thousands of people laughing
and going like, holy fuck. Usually that happens when the joke doesn't land. It's fucking 20,000 silent people and you're standing there going, oh fuck. That's much more powerful, yeah. That's a real powerful moment. Well, you know, one of the interesting things that I found in just the short amount of time
that I did it just in the small clubs over at the underground and at the cellar rather and at the one time in Austin is that, like we went one night and we were working on something and we went to the cellar in that main room downstairs and it went great. We're like, holy shit, that really worked. And then we went around the corner of the underground
20 minutes later, and it was like, pretty good. It was the same material, and it was pretty good, right? It was a big room. And then we went to the fat black pussycat next door, and it was absolutely bombed. And I remember at the time, Bradley was there and my buddy Bob, who you met, and they were in the back and they were dying laughing
because literally the same material that 30 minutes ago had killed, silence. Yeah, yeah. It's the best feeling in the world watching one of your friends bomb. Nothing better. It's the most fun possible thing. But yeah, that happens.
And it happens, but what's crazy in that feeling was, which was like, oh, it's just you. There's nowhere to hide. You can't, you're just up there. You can't just go, you can't start crying and drop the microphone and run off stage. You know what I mean? You could.
But talk about that, you guys. Because I think an actor can ruin a good script and they can also make a bad script good just based on performance, whether it's good performance or bad performance. Do you find that it's the same way with stand-up? Like in your case, Will, you had the same material, three different places. How much of it do you think was the audience,
or was it you in the different way in which you were telling a joke? I don't have enough experience to really answer that. In that moment, I have to blame the audience just to maintain my self-esteem. But Shane, you have a lot more years of experience. I mean, what do you think it is? Like are there bulletproof jokes?
You know, like any, you know. There should be, and you think you have one. Like a good example, the cellar is a perfect example because it's like four different rooms. And so like I would do, there was one night I did the Village Underground, which is a great room downstairs. It's one of my favorite rooms in the country,
but I killed, I was doing, it was crazy, I couldn't believe how good it was. And then I was on next upstairs, so I literally walked off stage and walked on stage upstairs. And in your head you're like, oh, I just, you go on with the same confidence you just had from killing, where you're like,
this crowd's, wait till they fucking see this. The first joke doesn't work, and you're just immediately crushed. So it's kind of a mix of the crowd and you. You went up there kind of fucking arrogant, and then as soon as they fucking shut you down, you're like, I just shut down completely. And then at the end of my set,
I did like a fucking Trump joke and they all laughed and I was like, fuck you guys, you guys hated me this whole time. You don't get to laugh now, I hate you guys. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. Are you doing any acting at all? Have you, how's that?
Well, he's got his show, he's got a second season of his show, Tires, that he created. Oh, great. Okay, gotcha. How do you like that where the words, you've got to fit the words as opposed to the words have to fit you when you're doing standup? I don't mind it.
I really like acting, especially on Tires, because that's just me and my friends, and it's all just our friends, so we can kind of fuck around, and you don't really have, you know, you can improv a little on that. Gotcha. I do have some kind of real acting coming up
in a couple weeks, and I'm pretty nervous about that. We'll see how that goes. Oh, can you tell us what it is? My show's not real. I don't know if I can tell you, that. We'll see how that goes. Oh, can you tell us what it is? My show's not real. I don't know if I can tell you, so. Okay, no worries. But it's material that you haven't written and you can't improvise, so you've gotta like
study these lines, learn these lines, and play your character in such a way where it makes sense that these lines come out of that mouth, right? I mean, like, it's a different. Yes, and it's a serious director, yeah, it's scary. And it's with real actors, and that's gonna be, yeah. Oh boy.
I mean, not real actors, I'm not like shitting on my friends. But yes, you are. Yeah, you are. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And they deserve it. No, this one's real, it's not that bullshit. Yeah. Yeah.
What does your family think about, could you talk is your family think about? Could you talk about your family sometimes in your in your standup and you in and you're obviously really close to them? What do they what's their reaction been to all of it? Are they like caught up in the whirlwind to the are they are they freaked out? Yeah, it took them. It took them a while they Yeah, they weren't on board for a long time and then They weren't on board for a long time, especially early. I did a YouTube special, it was the first thing I put out, and in it I talk about my sister and her addiction. I talk about my sister doing heroin on a YouTube special,
and she was like, what the fuck? I was like, trust me, trust me, it's going to work for us. She's just gonna hang up on me. Trust me, it's gonna pay off for me. It's gonna pay off for me. All right, oh my God. No, she got an apartment and a Chevy Cruze out of it. She's all right.
Okay, sure, sure, Chevy Cruze, there you go. How do you like life on the road? How do you like, what is that like from a social standpoint? I'm sure you're not meeting a lot of new friends out there. What's dating like and all that kind of stuff? Were you married? I'm not married. I have a girlfriend.
She lives here with me in Austin. She comes on the road sometimes. If it's like a cool venue, she'll come. Like this weekend I'm going to, tomorrow I gotta go to Knoxville, Tennessee, and then Birmingham, Alabama. So I think she's gonna sit this one out. Okay.
But, she's not coming. How do you get your, because when you're not in the mood, you're set to go on at a certain time, it's kind of like Broadway or theater or whatever, it doesn't, you can't have a headache, you can't have a stomach ache, you can't have like, you have to go on,
you have to deliver, right? So how do you get by that? Like, how do you prepare yourself if you're not feeling? And Jason also has a follow-up question for sure. What happens when you have to take a shit depending on what you eat? Jason, we'll get to that in a second. Because if you haven't emptied, you know, you got...
The shit goes away, right away. The adrenaline in the stand-up, the shit goes away, the headache goes away, the nausea, like, because I've done shows, a lot of the standup, the shit goes away, the headache goes away, the nausea, like, because I've done shows, a lot of shows hung over, and I've been like, oh, this is going to be terrible. And then as soon as you get on stage, it cares it. Yeah, yeah, and then interesting.
Other than one, I had one show, I did Crypto Arena in LA, and it was, I did the forum the night before, it was the best week ever. I did the Greek the night before, it was the best week ever. I did the Greek the night before, then the forum, then Crypto. It was incredible, but after the forum, I'm buddies with Post Malone and he came to the show, we're hanging out and it's like 2 a.m. after the show.
I have to do Crypto in the morning, but he was like, do you want to come to my studio and listen to my new album? And I was like, yeah, definitely. So then he kept us there. We drank till like 6 a.m. And the whole time I was looking at my watch like, oh shit. So then I wake up and it's I wake up at like 4 p.m. The car is outside to take me to my next show.
And I was like, all right, this this hangover will go away. I've done this a million times. The hangover just didn't go away on stage. And I kind of fucking bombed the crypto. Oh really? Oh no. Yeah, it was like the biggest show of my life. Did you let the crowd know?
They could see it. There was a jumbo drum on my face. They could see it. They could smell it on the jumbo drum. They could smell light beer. So Shane, do you have anything like, you know, for endurance when you perform on stage, like do you work out, like how do you keep up your energy?
I just, I literally just started a trainer. I'm on week two, I got to go to that today. Good for you. Yeah, I saw some photos and I was like, all right. Oh boy. It's time to. Yeah, yeah. How do you like that, an appointment for working out? I need it, otherwise I would, you know,
after this I would go, well that was tough, that was a long day, I'm going to take a nap. Right. Right, I'm kind of the same way. Well, Sean, Sean, I was going to say, and Shane, I'll pose it to you too, obviously diet is such a huge thing, like the things that you put in,
and Sean, Sean, we always say, Sean eats like he's going to a 12 year old's birthday party, every meal, every day. It's true. It's true, right Sean? Yeah, yeah, it's true. What did you have, what have you had so far today, if anything?
Well, it's so funny you say that. I did have a Pop Tart, but then after, I'm just saying, I really did, but then I had a bowl, like I had yogurt with berries, because I was like, I have to balance it with something. You have to offset it. But then like, but my brain works in the way that like, well, I did that so I can have spaghetti for lunch.
Right. Right. And do you have dessert at lunch? You do, don't you? Sometimes I do. But JB, like we'll play golf and he'll be like, hey, can I just get a couple slices of apples and a handful of nuts please? And then that's all he'll eat.
This is, I'm not making, I'm not even exaggerating, that's what it'll have. And I said to him one time, I said, you know what? You're doing all this, eating nuts and the thing, and you're still, you're gonna fucking die at 65 and I'm gonna be standing at your hospital bed eating a sundae with 30 years to go. You know what I mean?
But I'll look nice and thin there in the box. Jesus Christ. Jesus Christ. Oh, he died without any water weight. Look at him, beautiful. Shay, what do you think, so now you're gonna go do this serious movie with these serious actors,
and again, no offense to your buddies. Hopefully, yeah. Hopefully, right. Hopefully, hopefully, hopefully. But is that for you, is that the target for you? Is that what you wanna do? Are you doing it just because you have opportunity
and it's coming at you? Like where do you see yourself? Do you have a plan for the next five years or are you just like fuck it, whatever happens, happens? I think it's more fuck it, whatever happens. I'd like to just kind of work with my friends, kind of, if I could, the goal would probably be like the Sandler route, which is just
putting out movies with me and my friends. And then stand up, I'll always, stand up's always number one. Just stick with that. Would you consider stand up. I'll always stand ups always number one. Yeah, just with that would you consider stand up like Your job and your hobby in a way like you just love doing it when you have time Yeah, for sure people are like, yeah, that's the only thing I do really people like what do you what else do you do? It's like that's kind of it. That's it So your days are filled with maybe getting it going to the gym with it with the trainer Maybe go to the gym, a lot of Xbox, then stand up.
Sure, sure, sure. Pretty pathetic. What's the current Xbox favorite? Right now, there's a game called Hell Let Loose that's pretty awesome. It's just a World War II. What's it called? Hell Let Loose. Hell Let Loose.
Is there a headset involved with this? There is. People take it very seriously, which is pretty funny. Like guys, it's like- Are you playing multiplayer? Yeah, it's multiplayer and guys take it very seriously. It's like a World War II simulation, so there's no radar or anything. It's very funny.
There's guys, you'll turn your headphone on, on guys will be like I need ammo on this hill Where are the fuck? That sounds so crazy and also how do you spell that Now the game rules who are you got who are your did did you have standup idols, Shane, or do you? Yeah, it was always Louis and Chappelle and yeah. Yeah, for sure. Was it surreal when you started doing it and then you started seeing those guys out in the world,
was that surreal as hell? Yeah, now I'm like, I'm friends with both of them. It's crazy, I was just in Ohio, I was just at Dave's house two weeks ago. Wow. And he built a club and he basically owns the entire town. He does this thing where he brings in like music to this small town,
like an hour outside of Columbus, Ohio, where like, I was there a couple weeks ago and it was like Wu Tang was there. Wow, what? In a tiny 200 seat room in an old fire house. where like I was there a couple weeks ago and it was like Wu Tang was there. Wow, what? In a tiny 200 seat room in an old firehouse in Yellow Springs, Ohio. I mean it's crazy what he's doing.
Yeah, it's amazing. That's cool. Do you ever want to do anything like that? Like as you go on to succeed more and more? You want to do a hip hop band? I don't think I'm good enough to build a town. I do want to be in Wu-Tang. You're the best.
I don't smoke weed, but I had to smoke blood. No, I mean, wouldn't that be cool? I mean, your star is rising so quickly and so great and so, you know, incredible that you don't do you ever aspire to be like those guys to have that kind of ability to do things like that? I think that would require a lot of longevity, and we'll see, we'll see if I have it. I think you have it, I think you have it. You're not really bullish on your future,
on your mortality right now. It rose too fast, and now people are gonna go, all right, that guy, the fucking Bud Light commercial guy, get him out of here. I fucking love, by the way, I love your Bud Light commercials., get him out of here. That's how it works. I fucking love, by the way, I love your Bud Light commercials. I fucking, they're hilarious. I'm not fucking joking, they're really funny.
What's the one where you're standing behind the guy and they're asking him and then you just start drinking and I'm like, this is funny. It's hard to make a funny commercial, man. It's a very short amount of time, that's a very tough medium. We know, we do it too. Yeah, and you guys did great.
Oh thanks, yeah. I don't know, you ever seen that dog shit one that Sean and Jason did? It was fucking terrible. Listen, you know. Which one's that? Exactly, which one's that? They've made so many dog shit commercials.
These guys, I love you. I love you Sean. I love you Jamie. You're such a great work partner. Oh God, you guys are the fucking worst. Shane, listen man, you're such a great dude, you're such a fucking funny dude, you've been so kind and generous to me personally,
so I appreciate it. Thanks for coming to do this, we wish you all the best. You got Tire Season Two, premieres June 2nd on Netflix. Uh, fifth. June, sorry. Is that right? June 5th, yeah, good for you, thank you. Sorry about that.
June 5th, now we got to say it a few times. So June 5th. Yeah, good for you. Thank you. Sorry about that June 5th with now we got to say it a few times Yeah, June 5th on Netflix You you're on tour right now. You're touring like internationally on fucking arenas. You got your podcast You've got a tremendous amount of success wish you continued success. Yes, you're great dude hilarious guy Shane Gillis everybody I'm a big fan big fan of all three you guys you guys are awesome. Thank you Thank you Shane back at you. Thanks for a big fan, big fan of all three of you guys. You guys are awesome. Thank you. Thank you Shane. Thanks for being here. You're a great dude.
Thanks bro. Thank you. Shane Gillis. He's super fun. That guy's really funny. Yeah, he's got that real chill thing going on where it's just like, he's real, like, he's just a cool guy.
He's really low temperature. Yeah, he is. He's really low temperature. He's really cool. Jamie, remember we watched a bunch of his beautiful dog special at New Year's. Right, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. He's got that really unique delivery
that I find really, it pulls you into a standup where you kind of get into their rhythm. Like that's what I'm saying about Steven Wright. Like that guy just like, he's like Mike Myers in Halloween. He always walks towards the victim, never runs. Right, right, right, yeah. What a strange analogy, but you're kind of right. But he does, he pulls you in, he's great.
I mean, I've always thought he's so funny. He's like Al Pacino in Godfather 3, right? They just keep pulling you back in, you know what I mean? Godfather 3. Did they make a third one? They keep, Godfather 3? Yeah. It's a joke.
What are you talking? They keep pulling you back in! I love this line! Giuseppe loved that one. I love a Godfather, now I love my foot so. Where is number four? We, we, we waiting on the number four. Cuatro.
You guys, when you talk like that, you really sound like you speak two languages. Really? Like, what would you call that? What would that make us, Sean? Bilingual. Bilingual. Bilingual. Bilingual. Smart. Less.
Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.